hello Elizabeth congratulations it was
it was a very fine Victory today
um please tell me were you surprised by
Nana's choice of the opening today yes
because Dragon was not on my pipeline
when I prepared for her because okay
last dragon game was like 15 years ago
and then I was thinking like okay should
I go for the main line but then I mean
obviously like she might have prepared
T5 and this is quite concrete
and if I go for concrete lines and she's
better prepared it's not a good idea so
I decided like to somehow sneak myself
out of it but here you played uh castle
and uh well maybe it was sort of deja vu
you know situation because you already
played something like this and your
opponent played B5 but you don't
remember no first of all I don't
remember but it seems like even this
game must have been like 20 years ago my
fear system still works fine
okay so
um after Castle Rook fc8
um okay D1 for the moment everything
looks natural 97 you exchanged the the
dark Square Bishops and the four here I
like the your position very much yes
because I understood I mean like what
she did with rock FCA the 97 looked very
logical but when I was calculating it I
understood that after F4 she doesn't
have any good move because if she takes
on B3 then actually this is kind of good
for me because I will not have any
worries on the queen side and if she
doesn't take she has to be awarded I
will at some point take and maybe play
E5 and stuff like that so I mean if I
was in her shoes I wouldn't be happy
either because practically speaking I
think it's quite difficult for black
okay so it was Bishop B3 and here there
was a very critical moment I just wanted
to show you that the computer I analyzed
that the variation and it's it looked
completely strange to me here when you
played Rook D3 have you analyzed this
move well actually I when I played Rook
T3 I I understood she could play D5 but
it was too late because I understand
that I mean I'm a porn up she plays
Queen B6 and actually it I mean she
takes and then she plays Queen B6 and I
have probably nothing you know and I I
saw it but it was already too late
because okay somehow when a bed group D3
I didn't even think about the smooth D5
and then when I played it I saw it but
fortunately she didn't do it yes it was
a very powerful and very surprising
defensive resource so uh Nana didn't go
for this line and here there was a
critical moment let's say here where you
is it is it safe I mean I wasn't sure
whether I should play Knight E5 at all
but here did you consider Knight F6 well
I was calculated calculating it as well
and then I mean this is like the Dilemma
when you have to take a decision and you
you can go for the Tactical one with
Knight takes F6 where you need to prove
your Dynamic advantage or you go for the
Practical one where you just take some
material and hope it will be enough
and according to one of my coaches Tiff
Yakov it's always good to go for the
Practical choice you know but actually
according to my character it's much more
likely to play Knight takes F6 but
somehow I decided today okay why I
should uh I mean it's not risking
anything I wanted to play a five-year
King G7 and then I was even calculating
um here something like Queen D2 or
something
that's what I was thinking and uh of
tech C6 also interesting and Community
too but somehow I decided that with
Knight C7 I'm exchange up and if nothing
goes wrong actually it's fine but then I
understood in the ending everything went
wrong for me there was probably another
critical moment in the game here after
Rook D3 the computer as it is he doesn't
see much for you and and six was yes
probably a decisive mistake in this game
yeah she missed that I can open up and
her King is very weak
fortunately I saw that I mean I saw it
late because somehow
um well it didn't cross I mean I wanted
to play King D1 but then I understood
like that actually I cannot play it
because of negative two and then I was
really invited I play Rook D3 and then I
remembered I played Rook D3 because okay
she wants to play E5 you know f65 and
suddenly like this before and popped up
but maybe like she has to take but it's
of course like here I knew that I can
never lose but I can only win yes King
E8 and here I wasn't sure whether I can
take on B4 if I have to play Rook t7
this is something which I had to
calculate a bit but I think I would have
managed because I would have given like
one check to save time and then uh yeah
calculated but I was happy that she
missed before because suddenly the game
changed you know very preferable way so
somehow I misplayed the uh the ending or
maybe the ending it's just not such an
advantage as I thought it was I don't
know no I think the rest is a very uh
clean victory for you and you mentioned
one of your coaches so I wanted to ask
you what was probably the the most
surprising advice that your coach gave
you
I mean like okay I mean I was working
with different people and actually like
the most uh like the biggest advice I
got was actually from sergative Yakov
and he told me like when you are like
positionally better there is no need to
go for Dynamics because in this moment
when you go for Dynamics or sacrifices
you have to prove yourself but if you
just like continuing outplaying your
opponent positionally it's it's from the
Practical Choice much better and
actually he taught me this after I lost
the game in the world um world chaos
system I think somewhere like 2018
against Molina in the first round I was
totally like better from the positional
point of view and then I started to play
there dynamically the computer even gave
it but the problem was like the next 10
move sales I had to play correctly and I
didn't manage and this was a moment when
he told me this and this was a moment
when I started to kind of change my
mindset in a way that sometimes it's
good to go for the Press tactical Choice
also like for my nerves and for my age
it's actually not a bad thing thank you
Elizabeth that was a very important
victory for you you're back in the race
so good luck for the the last rounds and
well hopefully we'll see you once again
thank you well then Elizabeth and your
road ahead as we look uh to the Sprint
to the Finish Mike actually has